We have all seen horror movies where
radioactivity changes an innocent
creature into some terrible monster, a
mutant.
So what is a mutation, really?
Our features come from data encoded in
our DNA, just like a hard drive, this
data can get corrupted. That's what we
call a mutation. DNA is made up of two
matching strands. Each strand has a
series of four letters, and they're
matched in pairs. A mutation could mean
a change in one of the letters, or even
cutting both strands in two. Mutations
are happening all of the time. Most
mutations have no effect on a cell, but
sometimes they can cause dangerous
changes, like the start of a cancerous
tumor. On even rarer occasions,
mutations can actually be useful and
improve a cell. This is how genetic
changes happen in evolution. To fight
back against DNA breakdown, an army of
repair machinery is constantly looking
for changes in DNA and fixing it.
How can DNA damage be repaired? Once a
mutation is found, DNA repair machinery
destroys the damaged part and rebuilds
it. Since DNA has two strands, there's
usually a backup copy that could be
used as a template. If both strands
have been broken apart, they can often
be simply reconnected. Be thankful for
your DNA repair machinery, as a typical
cell in your body goes through
thousands of mutations every day.
That's several per minute per cell.
Without fixing them, you wouldn't stay
healthy for very long.